well grab your girlfriends and have a
fun night out on the town but hey let
someone else do the planning you can
turn to vegas girls night out to plan
your girly galentine's day and here to
tell us all about it is the ceo bree
steck hi bri hi thanks for having me you
know we uh we didn't coordinate but it
looks like we did we're ready for
valentine's day and we got our colors
ready to go so let's talk about it you
are so fun to follow along with on
social media you put together the best
packages for a girls night out so let's
talk about what you have planned for
valentine's day yeah well this one's
more for my gals so galentine's day um
well i've just been doing some really
fun things one of them is i went to
resorts world they have these pop-up
igloos that are really really cool and
it's um by vuv clacco so it's called the
rose rooftop and we went up there and
you get your own private igloo and they
have blankets and you're just gonna get
to hang out with your girlfriends and um
yeah so i filmed i put it on on tiktok
so everybody can see what it's all about
you can see right there look how cute
you look and how fun that is
we color coordinated as well we all wore
pink but you know it was just a really
really fun night out and so this is
something that i would say to look into
it's going to end soon okay so get on it
get on it but then they're supposed to
have more pop-ups throughout the year so
that'll be fun okay so more
opportunities to check it out let's move
on to your next idea i think it's super
freako right super freako i love
superfrico i just went there for the
first time it's by the creators of
absinthe so all those crazy naughty acts
while you're having dinner i love it
yeah it is a lot of fun the food is
really great and with vegas girls it out
i work with these different restaurants
to have exclusive menus so i go through
the menu pick out my favorite things and
then offer it to our groups but yeah
it's a really fun time and the last
thing we can't forget to talk about
everyone's favorite a little thunder
from down under that's part of the
package too right yes so we have a ton
of thunder from down under packages we
do all the group sales for them so we
work very closely with them we do a lot
of fun stuff like shout out and shots at
the show but it is such a fun time to go
with your girlfriends you laugh you just
you drink you have a good time and so i
always recommend it well for you you
make it fun for all of us and i've even
taken part in some of your packages
before and i can vouch that they are so
much fun and so organized which is
really nice to just show up and enjoy
the night so if people want to learn
more where can they go they can go to
our website vegasgirlsnaid.com or social
media same handle vegas girls made out i
put everything up everything i'm doing
it's up there yeah you're on it on
sunshine i love following along with it
thank you so much be sure to check out
vegas girls night out they can plan the
most fun night you will ever have
mercedes i'll send it over to you
all right now we've heard